Traduttore: Beatrice Vecchiato
Revisore: Maria Pericleous
Io mi occupo, da 30 anni ormai,
di sondaggi d'opinione e ricerche
e sono più che altro proiettato
verso le cosiddette ricerche
verso la comprensione
di quello che sarà il futuro,
quindi le previsioni.
Chi vincerà le elezioni;
quanto potrà costare un prodotto;
quale sarà la soddisfazione dell'utenza
per un prodotto o un servizio;
e cose di questo genere.
Ho notato che nel corso
dei 15 anni precedenti
non si è mossa una foglia
nelle tecnologie e nelle metodologie
che si utilizzavano.
Nel corso degli ultimi 15 anni,
invece, è cambiato molto.
Sono intervenute le neuroscienze,
le nuove tecniche statistiche,
ci sono tutta una serie di nuovi approcci
verso l'utente finale
che può essere consultato
rispetto ai vari eventi previsionali,
e quindi le cose si stanno muovendo molto.
Uno dei temi che mi sta molto a cuore,
e che sto cercando
di sviluppare, ultimamente,
è quello della cosiddetta
"intelligenza della folla".
Ma il tema fondamentale
da cui volevo partire era:
"ma è così evidente
che la folla è intelligente?".
Cioè, andando a pensare
nella nostra intuizione,
questo è contro-intuitivo.
La folla, di per sé, non è intelligente.
Una persona che è coinvolta in una folla
assume un atteggiamento etero-diretto.
Fa quello che gli dicono gli altri,
o sennò perde tutto il suo spirito critico
e assume quello della maggioranza
delle altre persone.
Questa è una cosa che per noi
è assolutamente evidente
quando parliamo ad esempio del web,
di internet, dei social network.
E vi voglio dare degli esempi:
ce ne sono a iosa,
però ve ne darò alcuni molto puntuali
che possono aiutarci a capire
di cosa stiamo parlando.
Questo, adesso ve lo spiego,
ma forse non devo nemmeno spiegarvelo,
questo è Antonio Cassano.
È un giocatore di calcio di serie A,
è noto solo per le sue doti calcistiche.
Hanno intitolato così questa news:
"Antonio, ricercatore universitario
di filologia classica
costretto ad emigrare
per i tagli all'università".
"È una vergogna, diamoci da fare,
teniamo i nostri cervelli in Italia"
e cose del genere.
Questa è una news comparsa su Facebook
che ha avuto una valanga di like
e un'infinità di commenti
a favore del mantenimento dei cervelli,
del fatto che bisogna tenerli in Italia.
Tutte cose giustissime:
però completamente decontestualizzate,
perché Cassano non c'entra niente
con tutto questo.
Un'altra interessante è questa:
questo lo riconoscerete tutti,
il leader dei Doors.
In questo caso
hanno scritto addirittura:
"Questo è Goran Hadzic, ha commesso
più di 50 rapine nel nord-est,
ma ogni volta che viene preso,
poi viene rilasciato.
Renzi vai a casa."
E tutte queste cose, per cui
ha generato una valanga di like.
Ma la cosa interessante,
che voglio farvi notare,
è che alla fine hanno coinvolto
un noto politico italiano,
il quale sotto dice:
"Sì, è una vergogna,
vediamo di sistemare questa cosa".
Quindi nessuno è immune dal problema
di quella che io in questo caso
definisco "stupidità di gregge".
Cioè il fatto per cui una notizia,
per il fatto di essere pubblicata,
viene dato per scontato
che sia una notizia già verificata.
Non si tratta delle fake news,
ma di quello che le fake news generano.
Un altro aspetto, ancora più interessante,
è quello in cui togliamo le fotografie
perché esse già inducono
ad un atteggiamento emotivo.
Togliamo la fotografia
e scriviamo una notizia di per sé.
Vediamo come reagisce la gente
ad una notizia completamente falsa
e che possono, in ogni momento,
verificare che è falsa.
Questa che vi farò vedere ora
è particolarmente interessante
perché sono una decina d'anni
che compare ciclicamente sempre la stessa,
e ha sempre questa valanga di like
e di gente che continua
a cliccarla, apprezzarla
e a fare dei commenti
totalmente a sproposito.
Eccola qua.
"Ieri il Senato della Repubblica
ha approvato con 257 voti a favore
e 165 astenuti -
e vi prego di fare la somma dei numeri,
che sono oltre i Senatori
della Repubblica Italiana.
Penso sia un livello un po' elevato,
per alcuni, ma per noi no -
ha approvato il disegno di legge
del Senatore Cirenga".
Sono dieci anni che c'è
questo Senatore Cirenga.
Nessuno si prende la briga
di andare a vedere che non esiste.
Sono dieci anni che viene fuori questo
e fa una strage di like -
adesso un po' meno,
ma sempre nella top list.
"Che prevede la nascita del fondo
per i Parlamentari in crisi,
creato in vista
dell'imminente fine legislatura.
Questo fondo prevede lo stanziamento
di 134 miliardi di euro -
anche qui, non occorre fare
tanti conti per capire:
una manovra più o meno
è di una ventina di miliardi di euro,
una manovra pesante
è sui 20-30 miliardi di euro.
Qua siamo a manovre spaventose,
e questo ti fa già capire
che è una bufala,
oltre alle cose precedenti.
"Che non troveranno lavoro
nell'anno successivo,
cioè alla fine del mandato.
E questo quando in Italia
i malati di SLA sono costretti
a pagarsi da soli le cure.
Rifletti e fai girare".
Ecco, l'unica cosa
su cui uno pone l'attenzione
sono le ultime tre righe,
quelle in cui si parla dei malati di SLA.
Quindi attenzione forte verso l'emotività,
totale disinteresse
per la realtà della notizia -
questa qui, la vedete,
qualcuno l'ha sicuramente già vista.
Anzi, facciamo così:
chi l'ha vista questa notizia?
Ecco, perfetto.
Ha messo il Like? Ok.
Però è un concetto chiaro.
Sicuramente, adesso,
che non l'ha mai vista farà caso.
Il prossimo anno la vedrete ancora.
Sarà ancora il Senatore Cirenga.
Saranno sempre 134 milioni di euro.
E saranno sempre 257+165,
più dei Senatori
della Repubblica Italiana.
Sempre uguale.
Cioè non cambia neanche il format,
così è e così rimane.
Allora la domanda è:
ma possiamo credere che esista,
posto che questa
è la stupidità del gregge,
possiamo credere che esista
un'intelligenza della folla?
Possiamo crederlo.
Abbiamo delle realtà
inoppugnabili e concrete
che ce lo affermano.
E vedremo anche se, tra la platea,
mantenete il concetto
di intelligenza della folla.
Perché 100 persone di voi
hanno fatto questo esperimento,
che mi interessa ora condividere con voi.
Condividerò con voi,
in diretta, i risultati,
e vediamo se siete stati bravi o no.
Perché l'idea di intelligenza della folla
nasce più di 100 anni fa.
La persona che vedete lì è Thomas Galton,
un centinaio di anni fa,
o anche più, 120 anni fa.
Ad una fiera campionaria
vide che c'era una riffa
in cui le persone
erano invitate a scommettere
quanto sarebbe pesato
un animale come quello,
pesato e disossato.
800 persone parteciparono alla riffa
e una persona si avvicinò
il più possibile al risultato
e vinse il premio.
Galton si fece dare gli 800 bigliettini
delle persone che avevano
partecipato alla riffa,
e scoprì una cosa sconvolgente.
Mentre alcune persone
avevano detto che pesava una follia,
e altre che pesava pochissimo,
la media delle persone
era assolutamente vicina,
con un errore del 5%,
rispetto al reale peso
dell'animale pesato e disossato.
Questo è il risultato a cui arrivò Galton.
A partire da quel momento,
sono iniziati una serie di studi
e approfondimenti metodologici e tecnici
per cercare di sviluppare
quello che veniva definito allora,
e ancora adesso, intelligenza della folla.
La cosiddetta "wisdom of crowds",
un libro del 2004
mai tradotto in italiano.
A chi ha partecipato al gioco,
questa è l'urna,
do i risultati in diretta.
Queste sono mezze penne rigate,
più o meno mezzo chilo.
Di chi ha partecipato al gioco,
qualcuno ha detto che qui ce ne sono 1800.
Va bene.
Una persona ha detto,
valore più basso, che ce ne sono 70,
Il dato reale è di 287:
la media raggiunta da voi è 272,
l'errore è più o meno pari al 5%.
Chi ha vinto ha fatto un risultato
minore della media
perché la persona
che si è avvicinata di più
ha detto che ce n'erano 300.
Quindi il concetto
è che anche in questo caso,
come in quello di Galton,
voi siete riusciti,
attraverso delle stime indipendenti,
in cui si accolgono
sia quelle più assurde in assoluto
che quelle in altezza e a ribasso,
la media, visto che
gli opposti si eliminano,
ha permesso di arrivare ad un risultato
molto, molto vicino alla realtà.
Questa è l'intelligenza della folla
di cui Thomas Galton
è stato il precursore.
Noi continuiamo,
qualcuno si era accorto
che stavamo parlando di Raffaella Carrà,
dei fagioli
e delle varie esperienze
che sono state fatte
in passato in TV;
però voglio aggiungere alcune cose.
A parte appunto il jelly bean,
che sono quelli che abbiamo visto adesso,
c'è un altro esempio empirico,
molto interessante,
che nasce dalla trasmissione
"Chi vuol essere milionario".
Ve la ricorderete tutti:
c’erano tre possibilità di risposta,
in una o rispondeva lui,
o rispondeva l’amico da casa
oppure rispondeva
il pubblico presente in sala.
Quando è stato chiuso il programma,
le statistiche ci danno chiaramente
un enorme vantaggio
nella capacità predittiva
del pubblico in studio
rispetto alla persona da casa.
Ci sono più o meno
20 punti percentuali di differenza.
Quindi anche questo ci conferma
che le previsioni
che vengono fatte da una folla
possono essere molto migliori
delle previsioni che vengono
fatte dal singolo.
Però, naturalmente,
ci sono delle caratteristiche
che devono essere rispettate.
Nel corso del tempo
abbiamo anche implementato
delle tecniche e delle metodologie
molto sofisticate
che ci hanno permesso di arrivare
a dei risultati molto interessanti.
Ve ne condivido uno.
Nel 2008, attraverso uno strumento
di prediction market
che sfrutta il tema
dell’intelligenza collettiva
di cui vi parlerò adesso.
Nel 2008, come vedete,
Nate Silver,
un americano molto preparato
nei confronti di questi temi predittivi,
ebbe un risultato strabiliante.
Come potete vedere, poté prevedere,
dei 50 stati presenti negli Stati Uniti,
fece una previsione corretta su 49 stati,
quindi ne sbagliò uno solo.
Questo è un esempio clamoroso
della capacità del prediction market
di essere robusto
e assolutamente affidabile.
Il prediction market, che sfrutta i temi
di intelligenza collettiva,
viene usato in tutti gli ambiti
professionali, pubblici, attuali.
Per esempio noi lo usiamo moltissimo
per fare le previsioni politiche;
ma è stato usato
anche dal governo americano
su studi sul cambiamento climatico;
è stato usato durante la guerra del Golfo,
è stato usato per stabilire i prezzi
dell’iPad Mini, ad esempio.
Viene usato dalla Hewlett Packard
per stabilire i bilanci provvisori
nel corso dell’anno
intervistando i quadri.
Quindi è uno strumento
che viene utilizzato moltissimo,
e che ha delle grandi
capacità di previsione
purché venga utilizzato
"cum grano salis", come si dice.
Ci sono delle regole molto precise
perché il prediction market
possa essere utilizzato, e sono:
il fatto che deve essere garantita
la diversità di opinione,
come è capitato a voi che avete appunto,
indipendentemente dagli altri,
deciso quante mezze penne
ci sono qua dentro.
Le vostre opinioni non devono
essere influenzate dagli altri.
Nessuno deve avere
il privilegio, rispetto agli altri,
di decidere di che cosa stiamo parlando
o quali sono le previsioni definitive.
Le opinioni poi devono essere aggregate
in modo da ottenere un risultato finale
e soprattutto, alla fine, un gruppo
scelto a caso risolutore di problemi
e questo è l'esito fondamentale
se rispettiamo le regole precedenti,
un gruppo scelto a caso
di solutori di problemi
dà risultati migliori
rispetto al gruppo
dei migliori solutori individuali.
Grazie.
(Applausi)